let me just interject for a sec cuz I
wanted to sort of get to a a specific
point um how do men typically respond
and react to your strong personality and
character how they do well um I don't
date a lot quite honestly I am not uh
I'm going through divorce phase it's
been one year so I haven't been really
dating but
beforehand um some men were very attract
to me attracted to me but when I was in
the relationship and those men usually
are the men that you call moth you know
strong you know Alpha very goodlooking
musculine have everything together but
once we got into the relationship they
said oh now it's my rules but I was like
but you were attracted to my you know
dominant side you were so attracted that
I did everything by myself in this big
country you know what happened to that
oh no now I went control you like it's
kind of like like okay I let you to
control me in the relationship but like
that wasn't what you were attracted to
me so it's always just like double
standards and expectation it almost goes
back to you right that's that's actually
a point that I wanted to get to so um
you know you're with a man somebody
breaks into the house you hear a bang in
the middle of the night downstairs yeah
does he elbow you and say Jasmine why
don't you get this one you know because
of feminism and women are all equal and
stuff and you're an alpha so can you
take care of it no that's not or do you
expect him to take care of it of course
I expect him to take care of it but how
can you call yourself an alpha if you're
not taking on the most Alpha role which
is
protecting protection is a different
story I think all women well actually
it's they're protected it's interesting
because um Jackie has a story on her
Instagram it says every man thinks he's
an alpha until it's time to do what
Alphas do protect provide produce for
their woman so you're calling yourself
an alpha but you're unable to protect
the household from
danger do you mean you're an alpha
amongst men or you're an alpha amongst
women wom exactly she doesn't with her
man she's an alpha alpha is alpha alpha
is
Alpha there is no such thing as an alpha
woman why there's no such thing as an
alpha there's a boss girl because
there's always a man because you're
unwilling to go downstairs and fight off
the Intruder okay feminine because
you're a woman and you're to be
protected by the man okay but that okay
in You Know wol Rich there is a research
about wolves that humans wolves Behavior
look like wolves okay and the Wolves
differentiated in three categories Alpha
Omega and beta okay you know what they
do they live among packs and the female
Alpha always fight with the other female
Alphas to protect her territory from the
other women you know we're not wolves
right research was debunked the research
was debunked it's no longer considered
serious it's why people get on us in the
space about Alpha Beta this we only use
these terms as placeholders yeah it's
not really it's not like we're basing
this in any sort of research or science
we're talking about these it's just the
words and the vacular of today like
somebody will come up with a different
term it's like high value man Alpha
they're interchangeable it's really the
same thing so they're they're not
necessarily these you know because
people always like to come at us and say
well Alpha isn't real and blah blah blah
and it's it's a it's a placeholder term
it's a representative of a certain kind
of person a certain kind of man I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out